الى ملف تركيا الان عقدان من الحكم فتح
خلالها اردوغان ابوابا جدليه على حكمه
قائمه من التحديات تواجه اردوغان في
ولايته الثالثه على راسها العلاقه
المتذبذبه مع الغرب فبحسب ولست ان اول
مهام الرئيس التركي تقويه تلك العلاقه
مجددا بعد ان كانت تقارب التركي الروسي
سببا اساسيا في احباط قاده امريكا واوروبا
وهو تقارب فسره اردوغان بالحفاظ على مصالح
تركيا هناك ازمه اخرى مشاهدينا سيواجهها
اردوغان خارجيا ما هي علاقته مع الناتو في
ظل اصراره على عدم انضمام السويد للحلف
وهي المساله التي قد تضغط على اردوغان
لتغيير موقفه حيث تربط واشنطن هذه الخطوه
بصفقه امداد انقره بمقاتلات اف 16
لقد تحدثت الى اردوغان وهناته هو مازال
يريد العمل على ملف طائرات اف 16 وقلت له
اننا نريد التوصل لاتفاق بشان السويد لذا
قم بذلك وبعدها سنعود الاتصال ببعضنا لكن
المكالمه في الاساس كانت للتهنئه
اما الامين العام لحلف الناتو يانس
تولتنبرغ لم يغلق الباب امام امكانيه
انضمام السويد الى الحلف وقال ان قرارا
بهذا الشان ممكن جدا قبل انعقاد قمه الحلف
في يوليو المقبل
ليس لدينا اي يقين وبالطبع نتحدث عن قرار
سيادي من قبل البرلمانات الوطنيه لاتخاذ
القرار السيادي بشان التصديق رسالتي هي
انه في متناول اليد من الممكن ان تكون
السويد عضوا كاملا قبل قمه لان هناك نافذه
الان خاصه بعد الانتخابات التركيه الان مع
تشكيل البرلمان التركي بالطبع ممكنه الا
ان تحركات اردوغان الخارجيه في ولايته
الجديده تصطدم بازمات داخليه ابرزها طبعا
الاقتصاديه حيث يواجه الاقتصاد التركي
وضعا حرجا في حين ان اي حل سيتطلب اجراءات
وصفت بالمؤلمه فالليره التركيه تراجعت
باكثر من 1% لتهبطه لمستوى قياسي جديد اما
التضخم فقد وصل العام الماضي الى اعلى
مستوى في 24 عاما متجاوزا 85% وذلك في ظل
ارتفاع الاسعار نتيجه اتباع سياسات
النقديه غير تقليديه يتبناها اردوغان
وتتمثل في خفض اسعار الفائده رغم ارتفاع
التضخم
لكن ايضا هناك سؤال ما مستقبل المعارضه
التي خسرت امام اردوغان سرعان ما بدات
اقطاب هذه المعارضه باستخلاص العبر من
نتائج الانتخابات والاعداد للبناء على ما
حققه مرشحهم كماله حيث عقد اعضاء الطاوله
السداسيه اليوم اجتماعا لتقييم نتائج
الانتخابات واقترح خلاله عدد من قادتها
على الاستقاله من منصبه لفتح الطريق امام
قاده الجدد لكنه رد بان هذا من السابق
لاوانه وتعهد بمواصله ما وصفه بمعركه
الديمقراطيه داعيه ناخبيه الى البقاء
واقفين على اقدامهم لمواصله المسيره
ورغم خيبه الامل التي سيطرت على المعارضه
بعد نتائج الانتخابات الا انها ترى في
التقدم الذي حققته نافذه لفرص سياسيه
قادمه وقال رئيس بلديه اسطنبول اكرم امام
اوغلو احد قاده حزب الشعب الجمهوريه
المعارض ان تصويت اكثر من 25 مليون اخر
لصالح مرشح المعارضه يعكس قوه الرغبه في
التغيير وادعى انصار المعارضه الى
الاستعداد للانتخابات البلديه في مارس
المقبل مذكرا بالنجاح الذي حققته في
الانتخابات البلديه والتي اعاقبت خساره
انتخابات الرئاسه عام 2018 كما ذكر بالفوز
في المدن الرئيسيه وخصوصا العاصمتين
السياسيه والاقتصاديه انقره واسطنبول
في اخبار الساعه لدينا بعد قليل الكونجرس
الامريكي في سباق مع الزمن لاقرار اتفاق
رفع سقف الدين العام
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات